Microsoft and Nintendo already worked  together once to bring minecraft to the  Wii U but could we get Mario games on  the Xbox someday if it ever worked out  Xbox executive Phil Spencer said he'd  love to see it happen in an interview  with us gamers he spoke about possible  future partnerships between the rival  companies he said I'd love to see Mario  on Xbox Nintendo has the strongest first  party of anybody they're just fantastic  and the memories that they have  instilled in so many of us who've played  their games and had those delightful  experiences having those on Xbox would  be great  Spencer has supported this crossover  content before he was on board with  making rares banjo a playable character  in the last Super Smash Brothers game  even though it didn't end up happening  we'll see what the future holds stay  tuned to game spot for more developments  and for all the latest from Microsoft  and Nintendo you're already in the right  place